in previous videos you've seen me
running Python code live on screen and
showing the results on this episode of
AI adventures I'll show you how to use
Jupiter notebooks to achieve the same
results the way I've been running Python
code live on screen is by using a Python
package called Jupiter Jupiter is built
on the ipython project and allows for
interactive Python to be run right in
your browser but it is so much more than
that from bash commands to special
magics and plugins Jupiter enhances the
Python coding experience greatly if
you're already using Jupiter I hope I
can improve your workflow and show you
some new tricks and if you're not using
Jupiter yet what are you waiting for the
easiest way to install Jupiter is by
running pip install Drupal err though if
you use a packaged Python distribution
such as anaconda you may already have it
installed so be sure to activate your
Python environment first and let's dive
in when running Jupiter locally you'll
connect to a locally running webserver
through your browser typically on port
8888 start your notebook by running
Jupiter notebook in your working
directory and usually Jupiter will just
automatically open in your browser once
it starts up but if not point your
browser over to localhost 8080 and if
you don't already have a notebook that
you want to open you can create one by
clicking on new and selecting Python 2
or python 3 depending on which version
of python you have running in your
environment jupiter is quite flexible
and it can handle many languages and
file types though we'll just stick with
python for now once you have a new
notebook running you can write some
Python code in the empty cell and just
hit control enter to run it we can also
run all our typical Python code here
just like you might write in a Python
script the difference is that we can run
it and see the results right away notice
what happens when we run a cell with
control enter the brackets on the left
side of the cell shows an asterisk when
a cell is running or queue to run and
then shows a number once it's finished
representing the order in which cells
were run during a given session starting
at 1 the results of the final line of a
code cell will be printed as an output
of that cell but only if the value is
not
toward to a variable so for example if I
import tensorflow
and then concatenate its version with a
string the output is shown below the
cell even though I didn't use the print
command and of course you can use the
print command and it would work fine
just as well now this is all very useful
for tinkering and seeing how something
behaves another fantastic feature of
Juber notebooks is the ability to show
the docstring of a function that you are
calling by just pressing shift tab this
allows you to call a function with the
correct arguments without needing to
look up the full documentation every
single time this feature also works with
your local custom functions so if you
write good duck strings you'll be
rewarded when you have a lot of output
you can reduce the amount of space it
takes up by clicking on the left hand
panel of the output which turns it into
a scrolling window if you double click
the output will be collapsed entirely
one cell is useful but really we want to
have many cells to add a cell click the
plus icon in the toolbar
there are also some cell execution
commands which can lead to new cells
being created for us if you press shift
enter it will run the current cell and
then just highlight that next cell but
if there's no new next cell then a new
cell is created on the other hand if you
want to insert a new cell immediately
after a given cell you can use alt enter
to execute the cell and then insert a
new cell directly after perhaps the
biggest feature that I've left out so
far is the markdown support my first
impression of Juber notebooks was its
ability to provide a great way to both
write code and describe the code I was
writing the rich semantics of markdown
allow for researchers and educators
alike to easily and cleanly communicate
thoughts and ideas but perhaps most
importantly it allows past you to tell
future you what a given code cell was
supposed to do in a way that can be much
more expressive than using comment
blocks sometimes I just want to do a
quick check on how long one training or
evaluation cycle is taking to execute
for an easy way to tie in your code
start a cell with % percent time
and once the cell finishes executing it
will print out how long it took to run
that cell it's not precision atomic
timing but it is a great way to get some
solid first impressions with very
minimal effort if you want to run a
command line command in your notebook
the easiest way is to put an exclamation
point in front of the command now this
is only really useful for one-off
commands if you want to run a bunch of
commands start a cell with % % bash to
cause the entire cell to be interpreted
as a bash script a great use of this
feature is to kick off tensor board
typically running tensor board might
involve starting a new terminal window
and running it on a command line which
is what we would typically do if we want
it to run for a long time but if we just
want to spin it up take a peek and close
it back down having it in a Jupiter
notebook cell isn't such a bad idea
plus you'll never forget to run since
it's embedded in your workflow of
notebook cells notice that it will
occupy your notebook see that asterisk
so you won't be able to run anything
else while tensor board is running to
stop it
click interrupt kernel the asterisk will
go away and you'll get back control flow
so there you have it some of my favorite
droopier features and capabilities this
is of course not a comprehensive
discussion of all of jupiter's features
I've just covered some of my favorite
and most frequently used here there are
many many more waiting for you to
explore thanks for watching this episode
of cloudy I adventures be sure to
subscribe to the channel to catch future
episodes right when they come out
but for now crowd rubber notebooks and
all that they have to offer